Some say it's impossible ending plastic waste,...
...but to us, that talk is just part of the problem.
Yeah, I said it.
What's up?
This one is for the oceans.
So let's not run away from this challenge.
Let's run towards it because we all have our reasons.
We run for our homes, for our families, for the next generation.
To help put our foot down on plastic waste and stand out for what's right.
It's time to run for the oceans.
And show the ones who have given up while we never will.
Oh my gosh.
Deep breaths brother.
In and out.
Oh my gosh.
We'll do it step by step, minute by minute, bottle by bottle.
You know, maybe they're right.
It might be impossible to do on our own.
But together, impossible is nothing.